hi everyone my name is luca nagoyda and
i'm
an ecologist and a data scientist and
i've always wanted to make a course on
r that i wish i had as a grad student
going into ecology
i think that one of the hardest parts
with starting a grad program in ecology
is really getting a good grasp of r
and it's frustrating because r is a tool
that should help us do good science
not stand in the way of it the point of
this course is really to eliminate that
frustration and anxiety so that you can
really start
plotting and exploring your data on your
own and feel really comfortable doing it
the project-based lessons and exercises
in this course are designed to take you
by the hand through the most essential
tools in
our beginning with things as simple as
how to install r
r studio how to upload your own data but
then getting into the more advanced
data wrangling data management creating
publication quality figures
learning how to organize your projects
and doing all of this while feeling
really confident
now this course doesn't cover any data
analysis or modeling
but that's really the point there's a
lot of our courses out there that try to
cover everything
and i think that can be really
overwhelming for beginners to really
grasp the foundation
this course is designed for students in
ecology whether you're a grad student or
an undergraduate student but really this
course is applicable to anyone that
wants a solid foundation in the basics
of art
if you're interested in this course
check out the link below in the
description so you can register
registration for this initial launch is
only open for one week
so make sure you register as soon as you
can thank you so much for watching
and please share this with anyone that
you think could benefit from this course
you